Skyrim special edition is coming this
friday to remaster Tamriel for your
consoles and Bethesda have revealed some
details about how each platform will be
handling mods in an FAQ on the website
the developer revealed that the games
total reserved space for mod content
will be limited to one gigabyte of space
on ps4 at five gigabytes on xbox one
this is much the same discrepancy
between the allowance for fallout 4 mods
which are given 2 gigabytes of space on
xbox one and when mods arrive on ps4
they'll have nine hundred megabytes of
allocated space as was previously
announced Skyrim won't allow ps4 mods
that use additional external assets so
you shouldn't be too constricted with
just one gigabytes in Skyrim assets can
be quite small of course you can also
delete mods and install new ones if
space becomes an issue but those two
recently revealed that Sony has been
blocking mod support for both flat for
and Skyrim remastered fight for is
expected to be updated with mod and ps4
pro support once bethesda finish work on
the skyrim 3 master will be arriving on
october 28 for ps4 xbox one and pc be
sure to stay tuned to gamespot for all
the latest